es ist ein idealer tag zum segeln auf
der flensburger förde ziemlich genau in
der mitte verläuft die landesgrenze
zwischen deutschland und dänemark eine
grenze die nie etwas trennendes hatte
sagen skipper micha und calw anheizen
der vorsitzende des einzigen dänischen
segelvereins in deutschland gegen korona
konnten sie wochenlang nicht mit dem
segelboot nach dänemark stillstand auch
die wasser grenze war unpassierbar
wir leben in diesem rhythmus hier in der
christ und das fühlt sich richtig
richtig gut an und es war schon fast
beklemmend bei aller schönstem
frühlingswetter auf die förde zu blicken
und die valeo
rückblick ein jahr vorher ist mächtig
was los in flensburg ankunft im fähnchen
mehr gefeiert wird magnete die zweite
die dänische königin rund 3000 menschen
sind dabei als die königliche jacht
einem hafen anlegt
empfangen wird markierte die zweite
unter anderem von generalkonsul kim
andersen und ministerpräsident daniel
günther der besuch hat einen besonderen
grund
100 jahre alt wird 2020 die deutsch
dänische grenze für die dänische seite
ist der besuch der königin der auftakt
für die offiziellen feierlichkeiten zum
jahrestag der grenzziehung die
nationalen gedanken des 1900 jahrhundert
teilten schließlich und hinterließen
ihre deutlichen spuren auf diese stadt
wurde zwischen deutsch und dänisch
entzweit
mein großvater christian der zehnte
heute 19.20 gerne gesehen dass flensburg
in mit dänemark wieder vereinigt worden
wäre
neue gedanken hatten fuß gefasst und
eine demokratischer prozess wo die im
gang gesetzt
die grenze war nach zwei
volksabstimmungen im jahr 1920 bestimmt
worden
so entstand im nördlichen schleswig
holstein die dänische minderheit zu die
sich heute etwa 50.000 menschen zählen
wie diese schüler am technischen
gymnasium flensburg die sich besonders
geehrt fühlen durch den besuch der
königin
das grenzgebiet sei etwas ganz
besonderes sagt margrethe hier ein
vorbild für friedliches miteinander und
das seit jahrzehnten so sehen es auch
vertreter der minderheit
[Musik]
sie besucht schleswig holstein nicht
also natürlich besucht sie in dem sinne
auch immer die bundesrepublik mehr aber
sie besucht ganz bewusst schleswig
holstein und das ist ausdruck für
wertschätzung des landes das ausdruck
auch für die lange geschichte die man ja
miteinander gehabt hat geteilt hat und
und und es ist auch dann weil die
dänische minderheit dazugehört ausdruck
für wertschätzung der dänischen
minderheit dutzende regale hunderte
dokumente im landesarchiv in schleswig
findet sich auch einiges zu diesem ganz
besonderen historischen kapitel vor 100
jahren konnten 582.000 dänen und
deutsche darüber abstimmen wo genau die
künftige grenze zwischen beiden ländern
verlaufen sollte wir haben ja eine karte
die ich als abstimmungskrimi zeigt mit
den verschiedenen bezirken und auch den
stimmenanteil am deutschen und dänischen
stimmen kann man das ganz genau sehen
für jede einzelne gemeinde fasste mit
der abstimmung verschob sich die grenze
nach süden
der größere teil ging an dänemark die
region um flensburg an deutschland in
beiden teilen neben seit der dänen und
deutsche mit eigener sprache kultur und
schulen wie eben im dänischen gymnasium
in flensburg
es ist ein riesen thema für die ganze
minderheit weil das ja ist das ja auch
in gewisser weise ein beweis dafür wie
gut dass es funktioniert und dass jahre
minderheit ist etwas schönes dass sie
die minderheit geschafft hat sich hier
zu halten und von daher ist für die
gesamte minderheit ist dieses 100
jährigen jubiläum natürlich ein
riesending es gibt ja ganz viele
minderheiten also den geht es viel
schlechter also wir sind ja sozusagen
musterbeispiel was minderheiten angeht
und ja ich heiße man könnte uns auch
fast schon als exempel für andere
minderheiten nehmen fast 8000
jugendliche besuchen rund 100 dänische
kindergärten und schulen interessant
auch für deutsche schüler die bisher
keinen bezug zu dänemark haben schon
ziemlich verbunden mit denen man eine
ganze familie auch dass mit dänischen
schule drei die ganz tradition über
halten das ist schon dass ich mir sehr
am herzen
dänisch als schulsprache berufschancen
hier wie dort früher so nicht
vorstellbar sagt der 78 jährige
handwerker jochen schulz dessen dänische
familie schon immer in flensburg lebte
noch bis in die 50er jahre habe es
ressentiments auf beiden seiten gegeben
heute ist es normal also ich habe viele
deutsche freunde bekannte und das
interessiert oder gar nicht mehr ob ich
denen bin oder oder nicht
man sieht sich man trifft sich als
mensch und werde dann auch so wie man
sich gibt wird man dann auch behandelt
auch lars bethge war schüler hier in
flensburg lange ist es her sagt er
scherzhaft er gehört zur dänischen
minderheit war in der küsten koalition
regierungssprecher für den
südschleswigschen wählerverband und hat
sich schon immer für die grenzregion und
die gemeinsame geschichte interessiert
1920 hatten die leute erlebt dass
preußen sehr viele jahrzehnte diese
region aus ihrer sicht besetzt hatten
und von daher waren die konflikte sehr
groß preußen hatten gefordert dass in
allen öffentlichen zusammenhängen
deutsch gesprochen wurde deutschen
kirchen deutschen schulen deutschen
behörden und das hatten teile der
bevölkerung hier der dänische teil der
bevölkerung natürlich nicht akzeptiert
und so waren die reibereien sehr stark
spannungen in einer unsicheren zeit nach
dem ersten weltkrieg
es galt die entscheidung der
volksabstimmungen zu akzeptieren
die dänen schmerzte vor allem dass
flensburg weiter zu deutschland gehören
sollte als die grenze damals gezogen
wurden waren die beiden minderheiten die
deutsche minderheit nördlich der grenze
und die dänische minderheit südlich der
grenze absolut nicht zufrieden
und sie haben auch in den folgenden
jahrzehnten versucht nochmal eine eine
eine bewegung der grenze irgendwie
herbeizuführen
das ist dann glücklicherweise kann man
heute sagen vielleicht nicht gelungen
heute müssen wir feststellen die grenze
liegt schon ganz gut da wo sie liegt und
wir können auch unsere kultur pflegen
unsere verbindung zu dänemark pflegen
unsere sprache pflegen ohne das
unbedingt die grenze bewegt werden muss
da haben wir ganz viel erreicht den
letzten jahrzehnten das jubiläumsjahr
hat 2020 soll also groß gefeiert werden
auf deutscher und dänischer seite
doch dann league ohne alles lahm mitte
märz beschließt die dänische regierung
kurzfristig grenzschließungen und
strenge kontrollen deutsche urlauber
müssen umkehren nur dringend benötigt
der frachtverkehr rollt weiter nach
süden und norden
für mich persönlich wird
höchstwahrscheinlich bedeuten dass ich
früher aufstehen muss um zur arbeit zu
kommen da ich in dänemark arbeite gehe
ich davon aus dass die kontrollen
bisschen länger dauern
ich finde es schon schade für den ganzen
grenzverkehr dem pendel den einkauf und
für die ganzen menschen die hier
wirklich hier nun her müssen aber aus
gesundheitlichen gründen akzeptiere ich
das und finde es in ordnung wir müssen
es nicht weiter verbreiten als nötig tun
inga rasmussen kommt mit dem auto aus
dänemark carsten thorsten hansen mit dem
rad aus süderlügum in deutschland seit
die grenze zwischen deutschland und
dänemark geschlossen ist treffen sich
die beiden frischverliebten täglich um
15 uhr am grenzübergang avendorf und
kaffee zu trinken zum klönen und kekse
essen bleiben und ich muss locker
bleiben und das war ziemlich glauben
aber fragt sie andere leute
das geht nicht das geht nicht ich sagt
er doch auf inka blog gefragt sie wollte
das kann ich hier hin
aber ich habe sie noch über überzeugt
eine liebe am schlagbaum doch umarmungen
oder ein kuss sind unmöglich in der
gemeinsamen zeit an der grenze an die
abstandsregelungen halten sie sich genau
das tue ich hab mich also tendenziell
vorsichtig und sollte man auch nicht
auch kein schon einmal handschuhe an
aber das geht auch schon gefunkt hat es
zwischen der 85 jährigen und dem 89
jährigen vor zwei jahren
es begann mit einem blumenstrauß und
einer wichtigen erkenntnis hat sie mich
auf der wange geküsst neben deutschland
können wir auf montag ist seitdem sind
die beiden unzertrennlich
verständigungsprobleme gibt es keine
er spricht fließend dänisch sie fließend
deutsch
liebe kennt eben keine grenzen
die ja immer zu meinen töchtern gesagt
die gehen ja zu tatsachen heuer ihr
kommen mit einem deutschen nach hause
und das war nicht mal dass ein deutscher
war das war bloß ich würde nicht
vielleicht kam dass sie ganz nach
süddeutschland oder nach ich weiß nicht
wohin ich sollten dem nehmen damit in
dänemark bleiben könnte und jetzt habe
ich sehr da die töchter was machst du
jetzt wo die jetzt hast du ja deutschen
inga und carsten machen das beste aus
der schwierigen zeit in der nähe und
zuneigung nur mit abstand möglich sind
und sie schmieden auch schon pläne für
ein deutsch dänisches ron diva an der
grenze ein anderer grenzübergang die
dänischen kontrolleure lassen seit mitte
märz also keine urlauber ins land
sehr zum leidwesen aller die sonst von
allein 16,8 millionen deutschen
übernachtungsgästen im jahr profitieren
die lokale politik wird deshalb schnell
die schlagbäume wieder öffnen
der druck auf die dänische regierung ist
schon sehr groß es bedeutet viel für uns
dass wir bescheid bekommen also dass wir
den deutschen touristen sagen können ob
die hier im juli kommen können oder ob
die reservierungen gecancelt werden ab
dem 18
mai dürfen hotels und restaurants in
dänemark wieder gäste aus dem inland
empfangen
doch unter welchen bedingungen ist
völlig offen die branche fühlt sich
allein gelassen mit der korona vorsorge
ich hoffe dass die informationsfluss
besser wird jetzt weil das war bis jetzt
nicht so gut
dann habe ich es mal ruhig gesagt es ist
der frust über schlechte kommunikation
in einer krise die sie in dänemark
inzwischen so gut beherrschen dass sie
im urlauber er den geldbringer als den
virus im tor sehen
wir verlieren hier 50 prozent des
einkommens aus unserem tourismusgeschäft
das sind allein bei uns zwei millionen
gäste die uns dieses jahr fehlen so
viele einheimische urlauber gibt es gar
nicht um diese lücke zu füllen die
deutschen kontrollen an der grenze zu
dänemark wollen viele jesus schnell wie
möglich zurück fahren
25 kilometer sind es von flensburg in
diese ziegelfabrik im süddänischen
broker zur belegschaft gehören neun
deutsche mitarbeiter die große sorgen um
ihren job hatten als sie von der grenze
sogar fuhr
für hoffmann kommt jeden tag aus
bredstedt in nordfriesland wie seine
kollegen konnte er in den wochen der
grenzschließung weiter zu seinem
arbeitsplatz pendeln mit
sondergenehmigung die der chef in
kopenhagen beantragt hatte es war so ein
bisschen ausgeliefert sein was kommt
unsicherheit müssen wir jetzt auf der
dänischen seite übernachten kommen
überhaupt noch über das war so alles
aber unser direktor des cern angerufen
und wir haben relativ schnell eine
telefonkette gestartet und das gut
organisieren
ja es gibt schon ein bisschen
einschränken man muss ein bisschen
früher zur arbeit fahren um an der
schlange stehen zu können an der grenze
aber im prinzip machen die es alle gut
für das mittelständische unternehmen
sind die deutschen mitarbeiter sehr
wichtig sagt chef christian petersen und
auch die mitarbeiter profitieren mit
vergleichsweise sicheren stellen und
höheren löhnen als in deutschland
es gibt viele deutsche die in dänemark
arbeiten einfach zu machen kriegen die
auch ein problem also hatte ich schon
die hoffnung gehegt dass hier als
grenzpendler darüber dürfen kurz danach
rief zum glück unser chef voran oder
unser direktor und hatte auch gesagt
sollte irgendwie größere probleme seien
kümmern wir uns darum kriegen wir alles
geregelt
das gibt natürlich so ein kleines
bisschen erleichterung in der ganzen
geschichte dass man sagt okay selbst
wären sie ja zu machen wir nicht drüber
kommen ist alles noch safe wir sind hier
sicher das passt denn für das
unternehmen selbst hatte corona keine
negativen folgen die baubranche boomt
weiter ziegelsteine aus vorgang sind
weltweit gefragt der export und so
weiter beliefern ihren 47 länder aber
die die ziegelsteine und co kammer und
das alles die kriegen keine corona also
können die überall auf der grenze über
die grenze fahren
die dürfen überall hinfahren wir liefern
nach australien nach amerika in tinglev
einem nachbarort stellen 450 menschen
betonfertigteile etwa für den häuserbau
her
rund 200 der mitarbeiter sind pendler
aus deutschland die ebenfalls weitgehend
problemlos einreisen konnten für alle
anderen auch die bewohner im grenzgebiet
war bis mitte juni alles dicht
dass die massnahmen getroffen worden
sind wendig völlig in ordnung und
richtig welche die sagen das war so viel
aber man sieht ja unser nachbarland
schweden die haben das ganz anders
angegriffen
ich meine das was wir in den markt
gemacht haben ist für alle das beste
gewesen
anfang juni mehren sich die stimmen in
der region die lockerungen fordern
gerade im grenzgebiet müssten sich die
menschen wieder begegnen können familien
freunde die infektionszahlen seien
gerade hier extrem niedrig argumentieren
die befürworter
ab 15 juni können deutsche touristen
wieder nach dänemark reisen
vorausgesetzt sie bleiben sechs nächte
freien grenzverkehr für die bewohner der
region wird es aber noch nicht geben so
will es die dänische regierung die bei
ihrer vorsichtigen linie bleibt auch
wenn es nicht allen hier gefällt
lockerungen wären schon gut heißt es
mitte juni auch in deutschlands
nördlichster stadt in flensburg die
wochenlange grenzschließung ist gerade
für die geschäftsleute ein großes
problem
natürlich fehlte das oster und
feiertagsgeschäft im frühjahr vor allem
aber fehlen jetzt die nachbarn aus dem
norden die sonst am wochenende gerne
hier einkaufen
es fehlen uns die ideen ja die diebe
suchen uns die die füllen diesen ganze
das des plans burg flensburgers dänemark
uhr ja wir sind einfach von touristen
abhängig und auch gerade von unseren
genen abhängig
susanne gehört stellt schmuck her margit
baron verkaufte im selben geschäft
damenmode bis zu 50 prozent
umsatzeinbußen seite keine schließung
klar die dänen fehlen sagen sie aber
fast jeder hier habe auch persönliche
kontakte ins nachbarland die nun auf eis
liegen sind nicht wirklich ganz schwerer
meine verwandten trieben in dänemark wo
und wie er den campingplatz auch als
dauerplatz drüben in dänemark gebucht
haben und warten jetzt wirklich drauf
dass der fünfzehnte vielleicht auch für
uns dann der termin ist wo wir dann
wieder rüber kommen können
grenzöffnung für touristen fünfzehnter
juni 00 uhr und keine minute früher da
sind die dänischen grenzbeamten
hartnäckig an den grenzübergängen wie
hier bei flensburg stauen sich seit
stunden die autos der touristen aus
deutschland zwei monate war die grenze
komplett zu jetzt wollen sie in die
ferienhäuser an dänemarks küsten und
natürlich auch alle die ersten sein
wir wollen dass angel nach dänemark eine
woche wir haben eine woche verschoben
wir wären eigentlich letzte woche dort
gewesen jetzt vorm heute und freuen uns
alle riesig wir wollten halt einfach
nicht lange warten haben mit dem
geschaut dass wir rechtzeitig da sind
gedacht das haben wir hier gute
poleposition und dann kommt kommt um 11
uhr hier auf einmal die ganzen autos
stellen sich ohne zu warten einfach
vorne mitten auf die bundesstraßen das
ist ein chaos wird das haben ja gelesen
im internet ich glaube 14.000 urlauber
werden alleine das wohnen erwartet und
jetzt schauen wir mal wieder durchkommen
um mitternacht geht es endlich los das
warten hat ein ende an den
grenzübergängen 56 stunden mussten sie
geduld haben
jetzt rollt die kolonne langsam über
landstraßen und die autobahn 7 richtung
norden richtung dänemark ich habe
gedacht ich bin der erste der hier ist
aber dass zu viele daran gedacht haben
muss sie nicht aber machbar
endlich soll die grenzöffnung vom gefühl
ist es wie 1989 sagen einige
nach zwei monaten lockdown endlich mal
wieder raus endlich ferien
dafür nehmen sie auch kilometerlange
staus mitten in der nacht in kauf
süddänemark die kleinstadt hadersleben
noch im januar 2020 freuen sich hier
drei generationen auf die feiern zum
grenz jubiläum mutter sohn und enkel
wir sind teil der deutschen minderheit
in süddänemark erklärt hans dieter kley
der hier als arzt arbeitet der 51
jährige seine ganze familie gehört zu
den nordschleswiger gehen rund 20.000
deutschen die als minderheit mit eigener
sprache und kultur hier leben können
man sagte immer vom nebeneinander zum
miteinander rum das ist auch wirklich
das was man spielt aber es ist natürlich
auch dadurch dass für zwei richtig gut
funktionierende staaten haben
deutschland und das gilt ist ziemlich
reichlich da vor allem für schulen wie
etwa das deutsche gymnasium in apenrade
rund 180 junge leute wollen hier ihr
abitur machen die meisten gehören zur
deutschen minderheit erklärt hans klein
der 18 jährige sohn von hans evert
zweisprachiger unterricht im
geschichtskurs geht es um bis markt und
dem preußischen einfluss auf die jungen
das bereitet uns vor auf 1 1 also ein
austausch mit den stars kullervo also
von der dänischen nasi um wo wir dann
über das thema mit ihnen reden sollen
und das ist so ein kreatives produkt
entwickeln sollen im nächsten jahr
anfang nächsten jahres im januar
und deswegen ist der
geschichtsunterricht ist gerade total
relevant zwei sprachen unterwegs sind
zwei kulturen am deutschen gymnasium in
apenrade lernen deutsche und dänische
schüler gemeinsam die schule als teil
ihrer identität wenn ich jetzt in
kopenhagen oder so will bin ich die
deutsche wenn ich in deutschland
irgendwann wenn ich die dänen
hier bin ich einfach ich also hier kann
nicht beides sein
gleich mich entscheiden zu müssen was
ich jetzt genau sagen möchte habe ich
als deutsche oder dänische bin ich auf
einem hof bei hadersleben lebt die
deutsche familie gleich seit dem 16
jahrhundert die enkel hans und lausitz
mit oma helene die noch einige fotos und
dokumente aus den 20er jahren hat auch
aus den jahren der deutschen besatzung
das ist heute so entspannt zwischen
denen unter deutschen minderheit ist
empfindet sie als etwas ganz besonderes
unsere minderheit hier die ich ja in
ganz europa bekannt glaub ich mein leben
war schon gut miteinander auskommen
das sieht auch enkel hand so der 2021
sein abitur machen will die deutsche
minderheit und die dänische in schleswig
holstein
das funktioniert sagt er wir sind ein
paradebeispiel dafür wie man aus an der
grenze nicht also nicht eine grenze
sieht sondern eher so eine möglichkeit
dar aussieht und also mehr geben ja ein
mehrwert schafft durch diese grenze und
durch die multikulturalität in
kopenhagen will er
wirtschaftswissenschaften studieren so
sein plan
doch auch seine schule schließt ab mitte
märz erst einmal für mehrere wochen
wegen corona zwei monate später mitte
juni können auf alle schüler wieder
zurück ans deutsche gymnasium in
apenrade unterricht auf distanz aber
ohne maske pflicht die klassenstufen
bleiben unter sich nicht nur hauptfächer
auch musik und kunst wie hier stehen
wieder auf dem stundenplan
die schüler sind wie überall froh dass
es endlich so etwas wie normalität gibt
doch das virus und die folgen sind immer
gegenwärtig das ist einfach noch mal so
klar dass es eigentlich zwei
unterschiedliche länder sind vorher war
das immer so ja dänemark und deutschland
man wusste es sind zwei unterschiedliche
länder aber jetzt ist man so richtig
getrennt irgendwie schon jetzt ist man
durch die ganze getrennt vorher war sie
offen jeder konnte nach deutschland
jeder konnte nachts in der mag aber
jetzt dazu jetzt kommt nicht jeder
darüber dass war merkwürdig aber auch
irgendwie schön dass man dann zu hause
sein könnte und einfach die zeit
genießen könnte aber nach einem monat
war das dann auch
ein bisschen fehlt glaube ich und man
wollte dann wieder seine freunde sehen
und all die anderen erstmal lernt man
hier noch mal eine ganz andere kultur
kennen dazu und dann hat man halt ist
man halt so weiter weg von seinen eltern
finde ich und man hat einfach mehr
freiheiten und ja ich weiß nicht ich bin
auch hier in dänemark sind die schon
besser ausgestattet als in deutschland
oft simone sippel peterson unterrichtet
mathematik
es ist nicht gerade das lieblingswort
von hans klein aber auch er freut sich
dass es kurz vor der sommerpause noch
einmal regulären unterricht gibt
wir haben ja auch einen brief an unseren
justizminister neben mark geschrieben
dass wir uns auch wünschen mit zusammen
der dänischen minderheit auf der
schleswig dass wir uns zusammen wünschen
die grenze wieder zu öffnen und der
justizminister hat sogar geantwortet und
hat uns auch ja dass er auch auf uns
hört und auch darauf achtet und jetzt
kriegen wir die grenzöffnung am 15 juni
deswegen auf jeden fall in einem
gewissen teil
simone sippel petersen hatte wegen der
grenzschließung einige probleme sie hat
zwar verständnis für die entscheidung
der dänischen regierung konnte aber eben
nicht einfach mal nach deutschland zu
ihrer familie schwierig für mich erstens
weil meine familie in deutschland wohnt
also ich bin eigentlich ein
familienbesuch geplant in thüringen
meine mutter liebt den thüringer und
schwierig auch weil ich eben
geschlossene grenzen kannte was meiner
kindheit und das war wieder ein schritt
zurück
also es war nicht ganz leicht zu
erfahren dass die grenzen geschlossen
werden muss man erst mal schlucken weil
man eben das aus der kindheit kannte
private einschränkungen gab es für viele
lehrkräfte sagt der schulleiter
schwierig war vor allem auch die ganze
organisation für digitalen unterricht es
gibt schüler die hat es richtig
getroffen also die arbeitsmethoden die
man braucht wenn man virtuell
unterrichtet werden soll
die sind andere als die die man hier in
der schule hat das ist das eine
und dann sind natürlich die sozialen
kontakte die fehlen sind das andere und
die sozialen kontakte
die motivieren natürlich auch zum lernen
etwas zu leisten und es gibt schüler die
können damit umgehen
und dann gibt es aber auch die schüler
die können damit überhaupt nicht umgehen
sind tatsächlich die sind extrem
benachteiligt gewesen in dieser zeit und
ich kenne ich kenne nicht wirklich ein
der gesagt hat er findet es besser
schule ist das eine für alle bewohner im
grenzgebiet war aber wochenlang alles
dicht und ist es nach wie vor kritisiert
mitte juni gut maria kann dusy
die grenzschließung sie spricht für die
deutsche minderheit in süddänemark für
die nordschleswiger wir zeigen uns immer
als als das tor zu europa unsere
grenzregion hier unten und 40 ist es tor
gänzlich dicht gemacht worden und keiner
richtig drüber auf weil es sind wirklich
wochen vergangen bis bis endlich mal von
offizieller seite signalisiert wurde
hier unten aus dem grenzland dass sie es
nicht in ordnung was passiert das geht
so nicht und das kann jetzt kein
dauerzustand werden auch nicht für noch
einige wochen oder einige monate es muss
jetzt eine lösung gefunden werden für
die grenzland bewohner dass das dass sie
ihr ihren ihren alltag wieder
zurückbekommen und zwar in dem tempo wie
es auch für die dänische bevölkerung als
ganzes möglich ist dann geht alles ganz
schnell
die urlauber sind mitte juni die ersten
wenig später können auch die bewohner im
grenzgebiet ohne kontrollen dahin wo sie
hin wolle vorreiter in europa waren die
dänen auch in sachen schule öffnung wie
hier in der dorfschule in rahlstedt im
süden dänemarks in mehrere gruppen sind
die 64 kinder seit dem schulbeginn nach
ostern eingeteilt und halten so abstand
zueinander
bisher hat das alles gut geklappt sagt
die schulleiterin
alle sind fit und wir haben kein wenn
wir krankheiten gehabt haben da haben
wir gesagt dass die kinder innerhalb 48
stunden wieder kommen kann wenn diese
keine symptome
es haben sich über erkältungen und
magenschmerzen und giovanni handelt wir
haben kein corona gehabt dänemark und
die schuleröffnung eine schrittweise
rückkehr im ganzen land zuerst die
jüngsten des klasse 5 unter strengen
auflagen händewaschen abstand halten
die planung musste schnell gehen sagt
pädagogin hanne die das kleine team der
zehn lehrerinnen und lehrer unterstützt
sie arbeiten im schichtdienst hier das
kind mit eigenem laptop
es war
ein bisschen anstrengend als wir
angefangen haben mit all den regeln die
wir haben und die aber die kinder haben
das so schön angenommen und waren immer
freundlich sonst und niemals haben sich
ist ja warum warum nach der lese stunde
gymnastik im freien unterricht draußen
gehört dazu sagt die 62-jährige hanne
während ihr kollege christopher mit den
älteren schülern englisch haupt
christopher hat eine vorerkrankung sagt
die schulleiterin wollte aber wie eine
andere kollegin weiter unterrichten aber
nur mit wenigen schülern um das risiko
gering zu halten
ich bin mit christopher geeinigt dass
wenn er nur sechs schülern kriegen und
sehr großer abstand dann konnte er
zurück und das hat geklappt und wir
wollten dass er wollte er sehr gerne die
kinder selbst kam mit der aufteilung in
neun gruppen von anfang an gut zurecht
detail kleine klasse ist auch ein
vorteil weil er hat so viel mehr zeit
und zu helfen anfangs waren viele eltern
unsicher ob das auch alles funktionieren
würde
jetzt gibt es hier wie überall in
dänemark wieder so etwas wie normalen
schulalltag nicht weit weg von radstadt
verläuft die grenze fast schon vergessen
durch die korona turbulenzen das ihr
seit einiger zeit ein zaun steht der hat
sehr viel trennendes sagen sie hier
aber vor allem wurde er gebaut damit
wildschweine nicht von deutschland
herüber kommen und so vielleicht die
schweinepest in die dänischen
großbetriebe tragen dieser zaun ihr für
viele in der grenzregion ist es ein
symbol der trennung der abschottung
es solle die dänische landwirtschaft
schützen und zerstört dabei die
europäische idee der offenheit schutz
für die landwirtschaft das geht schon in
ordnung sagen die deutschen bewohner die
direkt an der grenze und damit am zaun
leben doch irgendwie hat das schon was
trennendes sagt die 62-jährige angebaut
die hier seit drei jahren wohnt geteilte
meinung geteilte meinungen
wie gesagt ich finde das landschaftlich
schön ich bin sowieso auch für offene
grenzen wenn man so sagen
aber anderen seite kann ich auch die den
verstehen weil also ich bin schon so
halbwegs den ich finde den nicht
minderheit und dänemark ist nur ein
kleines land die kapazitäten sind da ja
ganz anders als hier jetzt in schleswig
holstein oder deutschland und da kann
ich schon verstehen dass die irland
setzen wollen wofür auch immer also ein
museum bei schließlich erinnert an eine
andere grenze der star keine große wahl
anlage die von den wicklungen errichtet
wurde und zeigt wie weit südlich sie
sich ansiedelten und versuchten
abzugrenzen
im siebten jahrhundert begann das alles
erklärt lars bethge der das museum seit
einiger zeit leitet hier gibt es auch
viele exponate aus der zeit der
volksabstimmung 1920 die zeigen wie
angespannt und teils kurios die lage war
dies ist das berühmte husumer protest
schwein ist soll angeblich gezüchtet
worden sein um in einer zeit in der man
die dänische fahne in preußen nicht
zeigen durfte um in dieser zeit sich
national zum denen turm zu bekennen
dieses wird als rot weiß bedeutet es ist
ein geliebter sattelschwein und die
geschichte sagt die ist von bauern in
nordfriesland extra gezüchtet worden
damit sie ihre fahne zeigen auch wenn
sie nicht zeigen dürfen
und hier in der litfaßsäule sind plakate
aus der zeit vor der volksabstimmung was
zeigen die man hat ja einen paten
wahlkampf auf beiden seiten geführt von
dänischer seite hat man nicht zuletzt
draufgehalten dass die situation in
deutschland
direkt nach dem
erster weltkrieg nicht besonders gut war
dort hat man dann den jungen der mit
einer streichholzschachtel spielen muss
und sagt mutter denkt an meine zukunft
stimmen dänisch und die deutsche seite
reagiert dann mit einem wohlgenährten
jungen mann mit schleswig-holstein fahne
daran zeugen soll
so ist es nicht wir können auch prima in
deutschland leben solche gegensätze
haben eine große rolle gespielt in
diesem wahlkampf das kind vor allen
dingen auch um finanzielle sachen bei
ihrem besuch in schleswig-holstein 2009
10 war königin margrethe auch im museum
danewerk der termin war er nicht nur
wichtig weil hier der weg zu einer
liberalen minderheitenpolitik gezeigt
wird das museum dokumentiert auch große
teile der dänischen geschichte
archäologische funde und schmuck aus der
wikingerzeit die königin in bester
stimmung
keiner hier ahnt dass es nichts wird mit
der geplanten feiern 2020 dieses besuch
ist für mich der bedeutend wenn wir
nächstes jahr die festlegung die heutige
grenze erinnern und sein können und
deshalb ist es wichtig noch einmal an
die minderheit zu sagen wir kennen sie
und wir umfassen sich mit großer
sympathie
nicht immer war es auf beiden seiten der
grenze so spannungsfrei wie heute daran
erinnert auch dieser ort bei sonderburg
die düppeler schanzen eine
verteidigungsanlage auf einer anhöhe
dort wurde der deutsch-dänische glich
1864 entschieden mit dem der ausstieg
preußen erst richtig gut an
dänemark musste unter anderem das
herzogtum schließlich an preußen
abtreten
auch weite teile im süden dänemarks
standen dann bis 1920 unter deutschem
einfluss heute ist die festung ein
museum und gerade viele dänen kommen
hierher ein wichtiger ort unserer
identität sagt der 62-jährige palop
alles in der seit jahren hier arbeitet
für die dänische scheele ist das ja der
platz das ist ja der platz der die
dänische geschichte wie geschrieben hat
der platz der däne mal zu das gemacht
hat von dänemark ots was er meint ist
das moderne liberale dänemark
skandinavisch gelassen und vor allem
weltoffen nie wieder krieg das ist die
botschaft hier
das sagt auch niclas bauer der gerade
sein abitur am deutschen gymnasium in
apenrade gemacht hat und hier jetzt bis
zum beginn seines studiums arbeitet es
ist wenn man mit den deutschen touristen
redet er ist heiß software wusste ja gar
nicht wie das hier war und solche sachen
aber ganz besonders dem grenzgebiet wird
dass sehr viel durch genommen so ich
habe dass ich glaube damit zwei verläufe
in der grundschule gehabt und im
gymnasium auch normal verlaufen also es
ist hier um einiges präsenter als
südlich von der wir uns auf jeden fall
das dänisch deutsche grenzgebiet
historische ort heimat für minderheiten
vor allem an den beiden küsten mit
toller landschaft noch immer gibt es
vier plätze die nur der natur gehören
wie der stiftungslandschaft haus auf
deutscher seite bei flensburg im juli
hat robert habeck daniel günther den
cdu-ministerpräsidenten hier
eingeladen für beide jedenfalls ist die
grenzregion von großer bedeutung
ich würde das heimat für mich geworden
ich habe so viele so viel erlebt hier
und durch die politik zugänge zu
naturschutzflächen aber auch zu
fischerei zu der landschaft gefunden so
viele leute haben mir das erklärt wie es
historisch gewachsen ist hier bin ich zu
hause und sie ist mir voll diese diese
region voll ans herz gewachsen
und dazu gehört ihnen auch diese
zweisprachigkeit oder die doppelte
kultur die damit verbunden dass sich
eine region die lange umkämpfte
blutigsten kriege die hier geführt
worden leute sind gestorben um die
grenze nach norden nach süden zu
verschieben
er hatte verständnis in kohler zeiten
das verkehrsströme auch eingeschränkt
werden müssen das ist wichtig war dass
man sich nicht zu sehr unter einander
austauschen das virus möglichst auch
aufzuhalten aber jeden war ja auch klar
das ist jetzt eine hoffentlich kurze
episode jeder freut sich darauf dass die
grenzen wieder geöffnet werden
und es war ja die ganze zeit einfach
auch immer druck von der bevölkerung
beiderseits der grenzen auch auf die
regierung endlich zu öffnen wir hätten
uns das sehr viel früher gewünscht die
dänische regierung hat dann irgendwann
glücklicherweise auch entschieden wir
machen die grenzen auch auf aber wir
lagen eigentlich immer eher unser
bundesregierung auch in den ohren macht
die grenzen wieder auf weil das freie
europa und gerade diese region ist hier
mit einer geschlossenen grenze schlicht
und ergreifen die ich nicht denkbar und
dass wir ja auch kein mensch und
glücklicherweise auch keine regierung an
diesem nachmittag entstehen auch die
bekannten fotos der beiden mit den
anhänglichen wildpferden man habe sich
sagt abeck schon vor zwei jahren bei
seinem ausscheiden aus dem amt als
minister in kiel zu diesem ausflug
verabredet und harbeck ist sicher dass
die grenzregion und schnell zur
gewohnten offenheit zurückkehrt die
grenze ist eigentlich in der im
bewusstsein der menschen eher eine
magnet liegen die als mit trennlinie
geworden da geht da passiert viel es
gibt einen ganz starken austausch sport
kultur die hochschulen arbeiten zusammen
also so erlebe ich es auch es nervt zwei
dieser grenzkontrollen aus kopenhagen
kommen
dieses symbol
hier ist wieder in der grenze und wir
schützen uns nach süden aber es kommt
aus meiner sicht eher aus kopenhagen im
grenzland selbst lebt man in so einem 2
kulturraum inzwischen und das ist die
botschaft von diesen 100 jahresfest
nicht dass ich die dienen oder die
deutschen durchgesetzt haben und man die
alten feindschaften wieder aufleben
müsste sondern das aus einer trennlinie
ein kraftzentrum geworden ist
in flensburg ist es gefühlt wieder ein
bisschen so wie früher sagt susanne
gelhard die in der kleinen seitengasse
der fußgängerzone schmuck selbst
herstellt und verkauft
mit beginn der sommerferien kamen vor
allem touristen aus ganz deutschland und
es ging endlich wieder aufwärts
nur die so lange vermissten denen sind
noch etwas zögerlich
die dänen sind noch ein bisschen
verhalten
wir wundern uns auch ein bisschen ich
glaube sie sind erst mal wirklich
anwesend um in den restaurants zu
verweilen
die kaufkraft ist noch nicht so ganz bei
uns angekommen aber es fühlt sich wir
merken die stadt jetzt merklich holler
ja es ist wieder leben
ich glaube was sie ein bisschen
behindert im wahrsten sinne des wortes
ist die masken pflicht die dänen kennen
keine masken pflicht und müssen sich
erstmal bei uns ein bisschen geht daran
gewöhnen dass wir erst mal sagen stopp
achtung abstand halten
auch in der boutique direkt nebenan ein
ähnliches bild die kunden kehren nach
flensburg zurück
also wir sind wieder an die vorjahr wir
haben ganz viele urlauber die den jetzt
noch mal dazu und es war toll kann man
nicht anders sagen
das spielt natürlich auch noch uns in
den karten der hof ist sehr gut besucht
und wir sind sehr zufrieden
nicht ganz so gut laufen die geschäfte
wie fast überall in den großen
modehäusern
die kunden sind zurückhaltend 2020 war
bisher ein schwieriges jahr
selbst wenn es in den nächsten monaten
besser laufen sollte
die ideen haben gefehlt und wir haben
die dänen vermisst auf jeden fall
deutschland hatte die grenzen
geschlossen der grenzhandel war nicht
mehr aktiv eine komplett andere
atmosphäre
wir gehen davon aus dass wir im schnitt
30 bis 35 prozent den haben im sommer
und jetzt sind ja gerade die
sommerferien steigen
diese prozentzahl auf bis zu 50 prozent
genau wie im dezember um die
weihnachtszeit
wir haben als flensburger kaufmannschaft
ja auch ein stück weit reagiert wir
haben den süden dänemarks schon beworben
haben gesagt schön dass ihr wieder da
seid wir freuen uns auf euch mit einer
großen panorama seite wir werden jetzt
noch einmal in den norden dänemarks
gehen und mit der politik aktiv sein um
unsere dänischen gäste zu begrüßen und
hoffen dass wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
dann auch bald wieder den anteil von 50%
unserer nachbarn hier in flensburg
begrüßen dürfen
drei monate grenzschließung ein
riesenproblem heißt es bei der industrie
und handelskammer die in ihren räumen
die geschichte des handelns in der
region in einer ausstellung zeigt
endlich gehe es wieder aufwärts
man merkt ja hier in flensburg dass sie
denen das straßenbild prägen wir haben
20.000 denen glaube ich die hier zu
dänischen minderheit gehören alleine in
flensburg ein fünftel der bevölkerung
und man merkt natürlich aber auch dass
die die tagesausflügler aus dänemark
nicht hergekommen sind der handel hat es
gespürt
die dienstleister die gastronomie und es
ist einfach es war gefühlt leer und man
hat schon gemerkt da fehlten ganze menge
die verluste aus drei monaten ließen
sich aber wohl kaum kompensieren
30 prozent des umsatzes machen die
kunden aus dänemark in flensburg aus die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen der
grenzschließung werden wir noch lange
spüren
glauben sie auch im segelverein der
dänischen minderheit wo sie sich einfach
nur freuen ihre segel leidenschaft
wieder nachgehen zu können
für uns ist alltag eingekehrt wo eine
einschränkung zu spüren ist es dem
regatta sport dass also die großen
regatten hier auf der förde
abgesagt sind auch unsere sehr beliebten
mittwochabend regatten auf der förde die
auch bei den meisten vereinen laufen
die sind nicht möglich mit den
dazugehörigen an zusammenkünften festen
usw
dass das haben wir organisatorisch als
zu aufwendig zu riskant angesehen
überall bei der dänischen minderheit ist
das bedauern groß deswegen corona die
feierlichkeiten zum hundertsten
jahrestag der grenzziehung ausfallen
kein besuch der königin kein
bundespräsident alles verschoben
doch gerne denken sie an den besuch von
mack räte vor einem jahr zurück haben
wir das große große glück gehabt dass
die dänische königin margrethe die
zweite nun anfang september letzten
jahres da war somit haben wir den
auftakt den haben wir gehabt und mit dem
wissen heute dass wir dieses wenn sie
jetzt in 2020 gekommen wäre das hätte
nicht funktioniert wegen corona die
dannebrog sound fährt dieses jahr gar
nicht also ein solcher staatsbesuch mit
königliche yacht hätte nicht stattfinden
können 2020 wir sind heilfroh dass wir
das gehabt haben und ich kann mal so
sagen innerhalb der dänischen minderheit
ist die freude selbst ein halbes jahr
oder länger
auch schon immer noch groß über diesen
besuch das ist bei uns täglich immer
noch im gespräch weißt du noch und wie
die königin hier war und nun war mein
segelverein der dänische der finanzpakt
wir waren federführend und haben eine
ein- und auslaufparade organisiert für
die dänische königin dass wir also mit
jachten und schiffen ihren gegen
gefahren sind sie in den hafen geleitet
haben und das selber auch wieder raus
leider bei grauem
das war also vor allem die die ausfahrt
war eine katastrophe vom wetter ich bin
noch nie so nass geworden aber es hat
mir riesigen spaß gemacht und sie stand
auch tapfer draußen hat auch mal
gesunken und es war sehr sehr großes
eigenes auch für mich persönlich vor
allem hat mich das sehr sehr berührt vor
corona waren die grenzen in europa fast
nicht mehr zu spüren
die einschränkungen der letzten monate
haben aber vielen klar gemacht dass die
große freiheit nicht selbstverständlich
ist